so zuerst mal direkt die gute Nachricht
der Woche also neben der Tatsache dass
Donald Trump jetzt seinen Kulturbeutel
für die U-Haft packt
die Ampel macht weiter wir haben noch
eine Regierung Deutschlands
zerstrittenste Koalition ever hat sich
selbst gerettet in einer 30-stündigen
marathon-sitzung inklusive Übernachtung
so jetzt aber die schlechte Nachricht
die Ampel macht weiter
denn rausgekommen bei der Pyjama Party
hier ist ein Papier voller Lehrstellen
und Fragezeichen ich will sagen der
nächste Krach kommt garantiert zumal es
am Ende einen klaren Verlierer gab oder
ja noch anders formuliert wenn sich über
den Tisch ziehen lassen endlich
olympisch wird
holen die Grünen garantiert Gold man hat
den Eindruck dass die Grünen ganz schön
viel schlucken mussten die Grünen
mussten all diese Kröten schlucken
Grünen haben hier Federn lassen müssen
natürlich eine große Kröte für die
Grünen die Grünen mussten sozusagen eine
Kröte schlucken das dürfte den Grünen
gar nicht schmecken sind die Grünen der
große Verlierer halt richtig ich habe
ich habe die Argumentation
gute Besserung auch beruflich
mein Mitleid hält sich allerdings im
Grenzen zum gearscht werden gehören
immer noch zwei und die Grünen sind
jetzt offiziell Teil einer Regierung die
das Klimaschutzgesetz aufweicht
abschwächtigt auf besonderen Wunsch der
FDP ist nämlich nicht mehr jeder
Minister für den CO2-Ausstoß in seinem
Sektor verantwortlich sind ganz klarer
Rückschritt und man muss ja wirklich
kein Körpersprache Experte sein um die
folgenden Gesichter richtig zu deuten
mit ihrem neuen Partnern wollen sie die
wesentlichen Fortschritte dabei jetzt
wieder abschaffen verbindliche
Jahresziele verbindliche Sektoren Ziele
die Pflicht zum sofortigen maßstörenden
ziehen nicht erreicht wurde ja ja genau
ist doch geil oder
ich sag mal 50% von denen hatten echt
gute Laune
das ganze ist eine lexising der FDP
Verkehrsminister soll nicht mehr
verantwortlich sein für seine Klima
Bilanz deswegen regeln wir das ab jetzt
gemeinsam in der Gruppe die FDP die ist
halt nicht so fürs Leistungsprinzip
weißt du da müssen wir ein Stück weit
Rücksicht
der Mann der ganz Europa nervt mit
seinen e-fuel-verbrennern die es als
Massenprodukt niemals geben wird was
allerdings das CO2 angeht da hat
überhaupt nicht der Volker versagt du
musst zum einen mal sagen es ist nicht
Volker Wissing der die Klimaziele im
Verkehr nicht erreicht es sind die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger
nicht erreichen so ihr habt es nämlich
verbockt
mit eurem ewigen durch die Gegend
gefahren und jetzt sitzen hier als
hätten sie nichts gemacht
man muss euch ein bisschen unter Druck
setzen was steht sonst noch drin im
Ampel Kompromiss eine Erhöhung der
Lkw-Maut soll dem Maronen Schienennetz
helfen schön gleichzeitig werden 144
autobahnprojekte doch beschleunigt
gebaut die komplette FDP Wunschliste
aber jetzt kommt neben diesen neuen
Autobahn müssen dann auch immer
Solarpanels entstehen genial wirklich
gut experten sagen die Trassen sind oft
so eng geplant dass da links und rechts
viel zu wenig Platz ist um relevante
Mengen Solarstrom zu erzeugen aber ich
sag mal die Geste zählt ja ne jetzt
nicht nachlassen grüne da geht noch so
viel mehr
überlegt schon alle Auflagen für
Schweineställe zurückzunehmen auch die
fieseste haltungsstufe bleibt
langfristig erlaubt wenn im Stall
mindestens eine Energie
gut wahrscheinlich geht es den Schweinen
da besser als den Grünen im Ampel
Koalitionsausschuss
ja Umweltverbänden und klimaaktivisten
stehen jetzt natürlich die Haare zu
Berge ist ja klar ist auch logisch
Olaf Scholz hingegen findet die
Ergebnisse der 30 Stunden Quälerei Zitat
sehr sehr gut
eine Meinung die mich sehr sehr ratlos
macht oder war das witzig gemeint
es ist wieder soweit Deutschlands beste
Comedians treffen aufeinander und wer
lacht hat verloren doch diesmal erwartet
Sie der Endgegner ein überraschungs
Komiker mit dem niemand rechnet
los und wollen jetzt erst recht alles
tun um die Klimakrise zu bekämpfen
die neue Staffel olafing out loud Witze
mit Bums
[Musik]
die neue Staffel
Olaf Scholz spielt ansonsten die Rolle
des einzigen Erwachsenen das
Erziehungsberechtigten der wartet bis
sich FDP und Grüne also die
verhaltensauffälligen Kinder müde getobt
haben das ist so das Konzept aber ich
finde Führung geht halt eigentlich
anders Führung geht anders tatsächlich
schlagen sich die Soßen immer öfter auf
die Seite der FDP und ich habe das
Gefühl dadurch ist beim Robert eine
gewisse Bitterkeit entstanden kann das
sein wie oft war es denn diesen
Verhandlungen zwei gegen einen also SPD
und FDP gegen sie
ist doch egal
mir doch egal ich fand die schon doof
bevor die mich doof fanden
machen wir uns nichts vor natürlich ist
diese Ampel eine reine Notgemeinschaft
ohne inhaltliche Schnittmengen was denn
sonst sieht man auch am sogenannten
Kompromiss zum heizungsstreit also
diesen Kompromiss den versteht jetzt
wirklich gar keiner mehr ab dem ersten
Januar 24 soll Zitat möglichst jede neu
eingebaute Heizung zu 65% mit
erneuerbaren Energien betrieben werden
möglich ist ein Wort das möglichst in
keinem Gesetz stehen sollte ne und jetzt
geht das Rätselraten los darf man ab
Januar doch weiter Gasheizungen einbauen
wenn die potentiell eines Tages auch mit
Wasserstoff laufen könnten kann sein ja
es kann wirklich sein auch das mit dem
sozialen Ausgleich beim heizungswechsel
bleibt eine Lehrstelle das ist ein
riesen Bock vom Habeck das hätte er im
Detail klären müssen bevor man
irgendwelche Enddaten für Öl oder
Gasheizung raushaut jetzt herrscht
maximale Verwirrung oder wie der Kanzler
sagen würde und das ist aber jetzt eine
Arbeit da sitzen wir in einem großen
Baum wo wir großen Wald wo wir noch also
viel tun müssen damit wir einigermaßen
dann uns orientieren können
richtig wir sitzen orientierungslos in
einem Baum oder so
Olaf Scholz ist trotzdem hochzufrieden
mit sich sein Trick Probleme für gelöst
erklären ja er sagt zum Beispiel wir
bauen jetzt vier bis fünf Windräder pro
Tag Punkt aktuell sind wir übrigens bei
0,8
die Bundesländer müssen 2% ihrer Fläche
für windkraftausweisen haben dafür aber
noch Zeit bis
2032 wenn wir daran nichts ändern wird
wenig vorangehen aber man kann es
einfach behaupten nach der scholzmethode
na alles zu viel Job Überstunden Familie
ständig will irgendwer was von dir dabei
kann alles so einfach sein mit der
scholzmethode du kannst nicht alles
erreichen aber nimm dir doch einfach vor
alles zu erreichen lerne vom Meister ich
bin sehr zuversichtlich dass wir ein
gemeinsames Ergebnis erzielen werden für
all das was wir uns für die nächste Zeit
vorgenommen haben das muss nämlich unser
Ziel sein dass wir das tatsächlich
schaffen kannst du vielleicht auch mal
den Müll rausbringen ich habe mir das
fest vorgenommen und ich bin sehr
zuversichtlich das ist mir morgen
gelingen wird dieses Ziel zu erreichen
lass deinen Worten endlich Worte folgen
mit der schutzmethode
so meine Damen und Herren
meine profi-prognose auch wenn sich die
Ampel ihr sogenanntes
modernisierungspaket unter Schmerzen als
Steißgeburt rausgequetscht hat der Zoff
geht natürlich weiter bei denen ja
natürlich zum Beispiel beim Neubau des
Kanzleramts den Christian Lindner
inzwischen öffentlich in Frage gestellt
die erwarteten Kosten liegen jetzt schon
bei 777 Millionen Euro ein gigantisches
Projekt das sich in der Tat ein wenig
beißt mit Krisen und Gürtel enger
schneiden Rhetorik machen wir uns aber
selbst ein Bild und schalten live auf
die Baustelle zu Christian Ehring vom
Architekturbüro Ehring Ehring und Erding
passt dieser Neubau noch in die Zeit ja
klar super was ja der passt wieder eins
gerade in Krisenzeiten haben die Leute
doch eine Sehnsucht auch mal was schönes
zu sehen viele wissen okay ich selber
kann mir jetzt keinen Eigentum mehr
leisten dann will ich doch wenigstens
dass mein Kanzler menschenwürdig wohnt
bis 2028 sollen hier unter anderem 23000
Quadratmeter Bürofläche ein Helikopter
Landeplatz auf Stelzen Wintergärten und
eine zweite kanzler-wohnung mit 250
Quadratmetern entstehen
machen die alte kanzlerwohnung ist total
runtergeruckt von der Merkel dieser
Mietnomade
wir bauen hier wirklich nur das nötigste
aha trotzdem darf man ja fragen ob das
Nötigste wirklich nötig ist schon das
jetztige Kanzleramt wusste ich gar nicht
ist größer als das Weiße Haus Downing
Street und der elise-palast
zusammengerechnet ja und wir vergleichen
uns halt nicht mit irgendwelchen
popeligen Sozialwohnungen ja weißes Haus
unser Vorbild ist natürlich Erdogans
Palast und den toppen wir aber auch noch
um 10.000 Quadratmeter kalifolaf 1
Sultan erdo 0
diese Baustelle sendet insgesamt das
falsche Signal ich habe gelesen ihr
fällt da gerade 60 Jahre alte Bäume ja
Buhu 60 Jahre alte Bäume dafür muss ich
ein 64-jähriger Kanzler bald nicht mehr
schämen wenn er besucht gucken Sie sich
unsere Pläne doch mal unvoreingenommen
an das stimmt einfach alles hier diese
diese geile Ovalform die ist übrigens
mit voller Absicht so geplant denn genau
da finden dann an urlaubsgeburtstag zu
seinen Ehren immer die Wagenrennen statt
wir haben das letzte Woche schon mal mit
Praktikanten geprobt außerdem wenn wir
jetzt den Druck der Straße nachgeben und
den baustoppen wären 100 Millionen Weg
ja und wenn wir weitermachen ist am Ende
wahrscheinlich eine Milliarde Weg stimmt
aber wir haben einen vortragbares
Kanzleramt übrigens inklusive eigener
Kita für 15 Kinder Baukosten 3 Millionen
Euro das sind umgerechnet 200.000 € pro
Kind ich bin das sollten uns unsere
Kinder schon wert sein
statt dessen night night night diese
blöde night-gesellschaft jetzt von
ausgerechnet die Liberalen auch noch
andere zu motzen die FDP schüttelt den
Kopf Repräsentation heißt nicht Luxus
man muss auf alles verzichten was
schönes Beiwerk ist man muss auf alles
verzichten was nicht unbedingt notwendig
ist
ach ja alle soll weg was nur Schönes
Beiwerk ist moment mal was liegt denn
hier aha ein altes Wahlplakat mit
schönem Beiwerk drauf kann von mir aus
auch gerne weg Heuchler allein für die
Planung von seinem erweiterungsbauer
haben sie schon 35 Millionen verballert
wenn er jetzt angeblich stoppen und da
stattdessen eigenhändig Wohnungen bauen
ich lach mich schrecklich so und jetzt
muss ich los machen da kommt die goldene
Scheiße heute für unsere 500 gästeklops
links vorsichtig runter weiter links
vorne vielen Dank nach Berlin
[Applaus]
wir stellen fest seine eigene
Wohnsituation hat Olaf Scholz also fest
im Blick beim Wohnungsbau für die
sonstige Bevölkerung sieht es eher Mauer
aus bauministerin Guides hat in ganz
Berlin schon so Zettel ausgehängt suche
dringend 400.000 Wohnungen Lage egal ja
Wohnungsnot ein Thema das die Bürger
möglicherweise sogar mehr beschäftigt
als ihre Heizungstechnik oder Autos die
mit vielen Staub fahren
das ampelziel mit den 400.000 neuen
Wohnungen pro Jahr ist unrealistischer
denn je der Deutsche Mieterbund fordert
jetzt ein 50 Milliarden schweres
Sondervermögen formulieren es Schulden
nur diesmal halt für Wohnung statt für
Panzer dabei Klang die Frau wird zwei im
Jahr noch so optimistisch das wird ja
manchmal ja bezweifelt ob die deutsche
Bauwirtschaft in der Lage ist 400.000
Wohnungen zu bauen
wenn wir auf dem hohen fahren können
können wir auch das
okay niemand ist jemals auf den Mond
gefahren und wir Deutschen schon mal gar
nicht aber das jetzt nicht der Punkt
meine Damen und Herren allein für 2023
fehlen wohl bis zu 700.000 Wohnungen in
Deutschland vor allem bezahlbare 100.000
neue Sozialwohnungen jedes Jahr werden
von der Ampel immer noch angestrebt nach
Schätzungen waren es im letzten Jahr
20.000 ja und weil immer mehr aus der
Sozialbindung rausfallen hat sich der
Bestand seit 2007 fast halbiert ist
dramatisch die Gründe sind natürlich
vielfältig wissen sie in der hohe
Baupreise höhere Zinsen aber auch der
Wust von Anforderungen unter anderem für
Energieeffizienz Bauunternehmen die
eigentlich bezahlbaren Wohnraum schaffen
wollen müssen inzwischen
Quadratmeterpreise zwischen ja irgendwo
zwischen 16 und 20 € nehmen um ihre
Kosten zu decken Fazit und da hat der
Mieterbund dann recht nur der Staat kann
noch im großen Stil Sozialwohnungen
bauen unter diesen Bedingungen
also er könnte
klarer geil Witz hat aber eine viel
bessere Idee sie schlägt vor wir sollen
alle aufs Land ziehen ja
ja hat sie wirklich und genau dazu reden
jetzt auch der Städte und Gemeindebund
Land ist ihnen Begriff oder ja genau da
wo die Miete günstiger ist und der
Handyempfang etwas schlechter
du
das macht was aus da hätte gar nicht
gedacht oben auf dem Dach da hat Heiko
Terme Empfang
ja ein Problem man kann zum Telefonieren
nicht immer ein Trecker mitnehmen
genau da hängt der Dorfplan von Frau
gaywitz immer noch Funklöcher zu wenig
Schulen auf dem Dorf kaum Kitaplätze
natürlich müssen die meisten Menschen da
wohnen wo ihre Arbeit ist und weniger
als die Hälfte der Jobs ist bei uns
homeoffice-auglich ne was soll so ein
Metzger machen
Tatsache ist also das stimmt nach
aktuellen Schätzungen wären ungefähr
600.000 leerstehende Wohnungen in
weniger begehrten provinziellen lagen
bezugsfähig daher kommt die Idee das
Prinzip ne in der Stadt gibt zu wenig
Wohnraum also ziehen die Leute raus aufs
Dorf ne dann kommen da auch ist ja klar
Bio-Supermärkte hin Schulen Kitas coffee
to go-läden Shisha Bars ein
Fußballstadion Büros damit man nicht
pendeln muss plus natürlich ein Park für
die Drogendealer irgendwo musste die
Drogen ja verkaufen und dann ist es da
so geil dass die Mieten explodieren und
dann sieht man eben von da äh ins
nächste Dorf ne ja ja auf dem Land
gibt's tatsächlich immer noch
unversiegelte Flächen das müssen wir
dringend ändern meine Damen und Herren
klarer geil Witz tut jetzt so als wäre
da eine bahnbrechende neue Idee gekommen
dabei gibt es den Trend zur Stadtflucht
spätestens seit Corona wohlgemerkt bei
den Deutschen die sich Job technisch
leisten können und die mit gewissen
Eigenarten des Dorflebens klarkommen
wenn Städte aufs Land ziehen wollen
müssen sie sich im Prinzip auf diese
andere Lebensform einlassen mit dem
Nachbar muss ich Kontakt haben ob bei
mir sympathisch ist oder nicht der
spielt keine Rolle in der Stadt hat man
nur Kontakt mit Leuten die einem
sympathisch sind
kurze Frage ist dieser Mann jemals in
Berlin U-Bahn gefahren
ich glaube nicht ah hier übrigens wissen
Sie vielleicht gar nicht jeder der trotz
allem freiwillig aufs Dorf zieht weil
die Klara das will kriegt jetzt von ihr
Ministerium als Staat geschenkt so ein
50 km langes LAN-Kabel
mit dem man dann mit seinem alten Router
in der Stadt verbunden bleibt
vielleicht hilft klarer geil Witz und
ihre Kinderlandverschickung der
gamechanger beim Thema Wohnungsnot
Schatz wegen der fetten Mieterhöhung die
klarer geibels meint wir sollen doch
jetzt einfach aufs Land ziehen ja
natürlich wieso sind wir Idioten nein
ich selbst drauf gekommen also kein
Wunder dass die Ministerin ist wenn
immer so tolle Ideen hatte
wir ziehen um und zu packten die beiden
den 4k Fernseher ein die italienische
Siebträger Kaffeemaschine ihre ganzen
Yogamatten und Meditationskissen und die
letzte Sushi Platte ihres Lebens nicht
ahnend dass kein Bringdienst der Welt
freiwillig nach kleinkrüttersdorf in
Vorpommern fährt wieder zwei Leben
ruiniert danke Klara geil Witz
e
in der Stadt gut aber spielen wir es mal
durch alle aufs Land damit der Plan
aufgeht muss vor allem eine
Voraussetzung dringend noch erfüllt
werden besserer öffentlicher Nahverkehr
denn da sieht es doch in den meisten
Dörfern er deprimierend aus wie Sie
wahrscheinlich selber wissen ne aber
nicht mehr lange nicht mehr lange
behauptet Klara gaiwitz durch das 49
Euro Ticket sei sagt sie die
Verbesserung des ÖPNV in Sicht
wobei ein Rabatt das Angebot ja nicht
qualitativ verbessert sind tatsächlich
startet am Montag der Vorverkauf der ist
49 Euro Tickets ab Mai kann man damit
fahren nicht mehr lange hin also höchste
Zeit sich vorzubereiten
[Musik]
das 49 Euro Quiz mit Tatjana Gertz
herzlich willkommen zum 49 Euro Kurs der
schaut zum 49 Euro Ticket für jede
richtige Antwort gibt sie alles 49 Euro
unser Kandidat heute ist der Oliver und
ich sehe schon der ist heiß wie
Frittenfett aus dem Bordrestaurant
[Applaus]
was kostet das 49 Euro Ticket
49 Euro
oh sehr gut na da hat sich aber einer
richtig vorbereitet was hut ab
Schweinchen schlau
[Musik]
nächster Frage warum heißt das 49 Euro
Ticket eigentlich Deutschland Ticket
Baby einfach weil es deutschlandweit
geht mit einem einheitlichen Tarif das
49 euro-ticket heißt jetzt ja auf einmal
deutschland-ticket der einfache Grund
Länder und Verkehrsbetriebe dringend
darauf dass der Preis auch steigen darf
die 49 € sind demnach nur ein
Einführungspreis
voll versagt da ziehen wir jetzt 49 € ab
Mann abgezogen ja natürlich im übrigen
war ihre Antwort sogar doppelt falsch
deutschlandweit einheitlicher Tarif
oh mein zusatzsermäßigungen für
Studierende oder sozial Schwache macht
natürlich jedes Bundesland manchmal
sogar jeder Verkehrsverbund sein eigenes
Ding Achtung Oliver aufgepasst
in Hessen sollen Geringverdiener statt
49 Euro nur 31 Euro zahlen der
sogenannte hessenpass mobil in Hamburg
Zahlen Schüler ab 1 Mai nur noch 19 Euro
für eine Monatskarte Azubis erhalten das
bonusticket mit Arbeitgeberzuschuss für
29 Euro im Saarland wiederum planen Sie
ein junge Leute Ticket für 30 € 40 bitte
nicht verwechseln mit dem ganzen
Saarland natürlich gültigem fertige das
kostet 39 €. so jetzt aber die Frage was
zahlen Hunde in Nordrhein-Westfalen
bitte Hunde dürfen in NRW kostenlos
mitfahren fürs Fahrrad muss man wohl
weiterhin extra zahlen zwischen
Wiesbaden und Mainz dürfen Fahrräder und
Hunde kosten los mit in Dresden kostet
10 € dafür darf man eine weitere Person
oder bis zu vier Schüler unter 15
mitnehmen
wo soll ich denn jetzt viel Schüler
unter 15 herkriegen das ist ihr Problem
hier kommt die Masterfrage okay
was zahlt ein 14-Jähriger Rentner aus
Dresden der einen Hund der Rasse
Labradoodle auf seinem Bonanza Fahrrad
nach Mainz schiebt und von dort mit der
Regionalbahn nach Koblenz zu fahren wo
er aber wegen eines Bahnstreiks nie
ankommt
wie alt ist denn der Hund
ach Mensch
schade seid es um Oliver hält minus 98
Euro inklusive Schufa-Eintrag aber er
gewinnt unseren Trostpreis einen
Tankgutschein und Wert von 5
nur
Mission Tankstelle
[Applaus]
hallo Leute Ich bin's der
[Musik]
heute-ersteller wenn ihr mehr heißen
Scheiß und liegt
dann abonniert jetzt den Kanal
was zur Hölle ist ein